l'homme n'a pas l'habitude d'être le
centre d'attention geomod pèse chaque
mot chaque intonation calme et posée il
précise qu'il n'est pas là pour attaquer
personnellement jodi white ribbon mais
seulement offrir une version bien
différente des événements il d'emblée
il nie que jodie wilson reebok et fait
l'objet de pressions inapproprié pour
éviter un procès criminel à snc lavalin
jobs
cela ne constitue pas des efforts
répétés et organisé selon lui autre
témoignage
la sous-ministre de la justice dit avoir
très tôt senti le malaise de jodie world
snowboard nathalie drouin affirme même
que le bureau de la ministre à bloquer
la transmission d'un avis juridique au
bureau du conseil privé
ce document détaillé les conséquences
éventuelles d'une condamnation au
criminel pour snc lavalin au même moment
gerald butts ne croyait pas que la
décision finale était déjà prise
ils ne voulaient qu'une chose
assure-t-il que la procureure générale
obtient un avis légal externe sur la
possibilité d'utiliser les nouvelles
procédures d'entendre de poursuites
suspendu même défense du greffier du
conseil privé
michael janyk en lui a rassuré plusieurs
fois que la décision finale était la
sienne
de retour devant le comité il a su en
avoir proféré aucune menace à aimer nos
france
l'ex-conseiller soutient que l'ancien
procureur général n'a exprimé ses
inquiétudes quant janvier au moment du
remaniement ministériel
le changement de fonction de jodi white
ribbon n'avait rien à voir avec
snc-lavalin selon gerald butts il
explique par le départ annoncé du
ministre scotch brite chine
elle aurait refusé le ministère des
services aux autochtones pour se
retrouver aux anciens combattants on
n'avait jamais vu quelqu'un refuser un
ministère ça a été le point tournant
dans sa relation avec joe dit woods a
manqué lorsque la confiance est brisée
entre deux personnes c'est facile de
voir les événements du passé sous un
éclairage différent plaide-t-il
et là réside la complexité de cette
affaire entre deux interprétations deux
versions qui s'affrontent